bonjour à toutes et à tous j'espère que
vous appréciez la nouvelle ses notes
scénographie nous sommes entourés de
deux tables rondes et nous présentons au
mieux n'y voyez strictement aucune
implication remarque politique
strictement aucune filiale
bonjour à toutes et à tous salle à un
petit point sur sur l'agenda
donc nous avons notre point presse
demain nous aurons notre bureau
politique à 18 heures mercredi le
président se rendra à la fondation
concorde et à 18h15 il tiendra une
réunion publique à londres et jeudi il y
aura une journée de déplacement de
nicolas sarkozy en indre et loire
voilà quelques mots sur notre agenda
sinon pour commencer cette conférence de
presse évidemment nous souhaitons nous
féliciter avec l'ensemble des
républicains de la réussite extrêmement
importante de nos trois candidats aux
élections législatives partielles qui
ont vu leur second tour se tenir hier et
nous félicitons extrêmement
chaleureusement pascal thévenot vincent
ledoux et julien dive qui entrent au
parlement avec des scores extrêmement
intéressant est sur une dynamique pour
les républicains qui est extrêmement
notable est que nous remarquons
évidemment avec une certaine volonté sur
ces circonscriptions
deux ont vu le parti socialiste est
éliminée dès le premier tour
ça commence à devenir une habitude pour
le parti socialiste de ne plus atteindre
le deuxième tour des élections
législatives partielles
on voit bien qu'aujourd'hui la réponse
apportée par le parti socialiste
difficulté notre pays
non seulement ne convainc pas mais est
immédiatement écartée par nos
concitoyens et que la seule réponse la
seule alternance la seule alternative
positif qui existe dans notre pays c'est
celle des républicains voilà nous allons
commencer notre point presse par
philippe qui va nous faire un petit
point européen merci beaucoup d'écouté
l'actualité européenne a été riche
semaine dernière avec le conseil
européen dont on a beaucoup parlé déjà
mais que nous allons tenter de vous
commenter
c'est un accord qui avait pour but
officiellement de trouver une solution
un début de solution à la crise des
migrants qui gagne l'union européenne la
grèce en particulier par la turquie en
fait cet accord est un accord qui n'est
pas un bon accord parce que l'accord qui
a été trouvé et un accord qui ne sera
pas ou qui ne sera pas efficace
vous savez qu'à une politique de 1 pour
1 qui a été décidé d'assigner de 1 pour
1 signifie qu'en fait l'union européenne
refoulera de la grèce vers la turquie
les migrants illégaux et pour un migrant
illégal renvoyé en turquie l'union
européenne est chargée de récupérer 1
qui attend l'application du droit
d'asile en turquie donc outre les
questions d'ordre éthique et
déontologique qui sont à mon avis loin
d'être réglée dans cette affaire on a
une voix on observe que
résolvera rien par une affaire d'un
point deuxièmement et c'est le sujet
politique majeur c'est que nous avons
tous aidé à la turquie qui dans un
accord purement de l'immigration en a
profité pour y introduire des
dispositions qui n'auraient pas dû y
être en particulier l'ouverture d'un
nouveau chapitre sur l'adhésion de la
turquie à l'union européenne
or vous savez que nous sommes de façon
constante
opposé à l'entrée de la turquie dans
l'union européenne est là c'est un
cetain pas réellement en avant que
l'union européenne a accepté mais aussi
une politique de visas qui va être
extrêmement libéralisé avant le fin juin
2016 donc il ya une date qui fait qu'à
partir de 2016 et bien les visas pour
les citoyens turcs seront quasiment
librement ouvert pour entrer dans
l'union européenne
et là-dessus la turquie a obtenu en plus
3 + 3 6 milliards d'euros au titre de
l'aide de l'union européenne pour la
gestion des migrants donc l'accord 1 et
inefficace de ne répond pas à la hauteur
de l'enjeu et je crois que les chiffres
c'est qu'on est à 170 mille aujourd'hui
migrants illégaux qui sont entrés depuis
le début de l'année dans l'union
européenne et le l'accord sur le 1.6
concernera 54 mille personnes donc on
voit déjà qu'on n'est pas du tout dans
l'enjeu deuxièmement ça a été échangé
contre contre
chantage turcs que nous avons accepté et
puis enfin troisièmement au titre de ce
que la france doit peser ou pourrait
peser en europe
nous sommes absolument désespéré de voir
que la france a été absent de cet accord
l'accord a été négocié uniquement par
madame merkel avec le premier ministre
hollandais qui est la présidence en
exercice de l'union et ces deux là ont
considéré comme acquis les dispositions
qu'ils avaient négocié avec lecture
directement la preuve est ce assez
simple c'est qu'il ya environ dix jours
le préaccord avait été présenté on avait
présenté sa com nous allons continuer à
négocier en tout cas le gouvernement
français et le président de la
république avait dit mais les choses ne
sont pas faites
en faite dix jours plus tard les choses
sont faites et nous avons tous et des
eaux turques pour pas grand chose là
dessus enfin dernier point on lâche la
grèce on va mettre la grèce dans une
situation absolument catastrophique
puisque la grèce va être évidemment
laissée à elle même c'est intéressant de
noter que les turcs reçoivent six
milliards d'euros et que les grecs vont
recevoir 160 millions d'euros
donc un pays de l'union européenne va
être moins aidés que un pays hors union
européenne la turquie sur la question
des migrants et au conseil européen il
ya eu beaucoup de choses qui ont été
décidés on va pas tous les citer mais y
en a un qu'il faut citer parce que nous
trouvons qu'il n'a pas été suffisamment
mis en avant même pas du tout d'ailleurs
c'est le semestre européen vous savez
dans le cadre du semestre européen la
commission européenne analyse la
situation économique des états membres
de l'union chaque année et va procéder à
des recommandations et donc il ya eu une
présentation du rapport france 2016 dont
là aussi le président de la république a
oublié de faire part à la presse cela
avait été discuté et dont le rapport est
très
est terrible dans son diagnostic sur
l'état de la france je résumerai par une
seule diapositives qui a été présenté il
ya actuellement des pays qui sont en
déséquilibre excessif c'est le terme
utilisé les déséquilibres excessifs
c'est la bulgarie c'est la croatie c'est
le portugal et l'italie
et c'est la france et donc nous sommes
en compagnie de la bulgarie de la
croatie en bonne compagnie comme vous
pouvez le voir c'est ça la réalité des
résultats économiques de notre de notre
beau pays sous la présidence de qui vous
savez merci je reviens en quelques mots
sur cette affaire turc ya quinze jours
ici au nom des républicains
on avait appelé le gouvernement à ne pas
franchir deux lignes rouges et céline
rouge elles ont été franchies il est
totalement inacceptable que le processus
d'adhésion de la turquie à l'europe soit
relancé avec l'ouverture de nouveaux
chapitres et c'est une folie que
d'accepter des juin 2016
en réalité la libre circulation de 80
millions de turcs en europe
les deux lignes rouges que nous avions
tracé ici elles ont été franchies par le
gouvernement et il ya pire
le premier ministre a été malhonnête
devant l'assemblée nationale mardi
dernier lorsqu en réponse à une question
que je lui posais au nom des députés
républicains
il a laissé entendre à l'assemblée
nationale que la france n'accepterait
pas la libre circulation des turcs en
europe
la vérité c'est que tout a été cédé lors
du conseil européen
non seulement la france n'a pas été à
l'initiative
mais elle a tout accepté et cet accord
entre l'europe et la turquie est au fond
un marché de dupes
on s'est couché devant monsieur erdogan
ça sera la fois inopérant pour régler la
question migratoire
philippe juvin l'a démontré la notion du
un pour un n'a pas de sens c'est
inopérant
gérer la crise migratoire et c'est un
abandon à toutes les revendications turc
encore une fois c'est un marché de dupe
et sait vraiment au plan géographique
économique que politique et même
historique c'est une vraie erreur c'est
une vraie erreur c'est une vraie faute
contre l'intérêt national qui sera
vraiment inscrit tôt au passif de ceux
de ce quinquennat
un mot sur la capture de cet individu
il ya il ya quelques heures à bruxelles
cet individu à des singes ii le nomme
pas parce que je pense que la quasi
glorification de ce terroriste n'a pas
lieu d'être c'est une racaille une
crapule un rate est un meurtrier est un
assassin naturellement au nom des
républicains
nous avons d'abord une pensée des
félicitations adressées aux policiers et
aux magistrats qui l'ont traqué et
qu'ils ont capturé mais nous posons des
questions
première question pourquoi cet individu
qui avait été auditionné dès février
2015 par là
police belge n'a pas été mis hors d'état
de nuire à temps deuxième question
pourquoi at il était en situation de
circuler librement à travers l'europe
tout au long de l'année 2015
troisième question pourquoi après les
attentats du 13 novembre at il pu
quitter le territoire national et se
cacher en bénéficiant de très nombreuses
complicités d'appui se cacher pendant
pendant pendant plusieurs mois
il ya là sans doute des failles
opérationnelles et organisationnelles
des failles d'organisation qu'il faut
absolument combler c'est la fonction de
l'autorité judiciaire de faire toute la
lumière sur ces circonstances de fait
c'est aussi le travail de la commission
d' enquête parlementaire dont georges
fenech est le président que de continuer
ce travail d'auditions qui cette semaine
encore à l'assemblée nationale se
tiendra cet après midi avec georges
fenech nous entendrons notamment le
directeur général de la police nationale
et ses questions évidemment seront
abordés il est prévu également que la
commission denquête se rendent à
molenbeek
comme elle s'est rendue il ya quelques
jours au bataclan ses déplacements sur
le terrain et les échanges qui
permettent avec les forces de sécurité
et claire utilement les auditions qu'on
peut avoir par ailleurs à l'assemblée
nationale voilà ce que je voulais dire à
ce stade je crois que valérie va
compléter car nous avons sur cette
affaire
de la capture de cet individu était très
désagréablement surpris par des
déclarations de monsieur cambadélis
effectivement si guillaume monsieur
cambadélis ce matin à oser indiqué que
cette capture cette arrestation
mettaient en difficulté la droite
sénatoriale française
ces propos n'honore pas monsieur
cambadélis ce à dire que cette loi
putative en l'état sur la déchéance de
nationalité n'a qu'un seul objectif
museler l'opposition républicaine est ce
à dire qu à partir du moment où
effectivement il y a un certain nombre
d'actes de procédure qui sont engagés
nous n'aurions plus la possibilité ni
d'exprimer ni de parler de contester et
nous sommes extrêmement choqués par ce
qui se révèle être la vérité
c'est-à-dire une façon
d'instrumentaliser instrumentaliser la
peur la terreur instrumentaliser le
terrorisme là monsieur cambadélis se
prend les pieds dans le tapis puisque
malheureusement pour lui eh bien ils
démontrent que le parti socialiste en
agissant ainsi sous est instrumentalisé
le terrorisme et la peur et ça je pense
que c'est parfaitement insupportable
dans une démocratie moderne dans la
démocratie qui est la nôtre d'essayer de
nous empêcher d'exprimer ce que nous
avons à exprimer d'autant plus que c'est
parfaitement ridicule en l'espèce
ce criminel est binational dont il
rentre parfaitement dans le cadre de la
loi et des propositions prévues par le
sénat donc nous nous insurgeons de façon
forte et solennelle compte cette
instrumentalisation manifeste